[Music]
so look
as we said before number one the
universe couldn't have come from nothing
yeah number two the universe couldn't
have created itself
because it's a contradiction it's like
something being there and not there at
the same time
therefore something must have brought
about the universe
now we have to ask ourselves what is
this something we say that something has
creative capacity because obviously you
brought the universe to existence
has will has power has knowledge because
the universe exhibits
the effects of those things and so we
call that god
yeah we call that god you don't need to
call that god for now
but having said this now the question is
can we have more than one god
the answer is no because you can't have
more than one all powerful you can't
have more than one all knowledgeable
entity so because otherwise they'd
outstrip one another
so there's only one god now this one god
that created the universe
has sent messengers and prophets by
abraham moses jesus and we believe the
final prophet messenger
was prophet muhammed and has sent books
like for example the taurah and the
indian
the gospels but those books haven't
survived and they've been corrupted
that's why you have different
translations different versions
different manuscripts all kinds of
things
as for the quran we believe has been
perfectly preserved
and it's the final message to humankind
guidance for human beings so does that
make sense yeah
so we say prophet muhammad as a final
messenger and that you have to believe
in the problem
yeah so um how does that sound to you
yeah no i i agree with everything you
agree with everything though
so if you agree that there's only one
god worthy of worship do you agree with
that
yeah and you do you agree that prophet
muhammad is his messenger yep
so we would say okay you know that's uh
that's islam what are you trying to do
what
don't you have religion on my throat
listen to this place
rock and roll
incredible nakamura is starting to feel
it nakamura's in that season
kept going back to the
[Applause]
sunglasses it's the most electrifying
move in sports entertainment today
[Music]
[Applause]
i
is
[Applause]
is over
you